there's the new cover tom brady patrick
holmes brady was on the cover of madden
in
2018 patrick mahomes in 2020 now they're
on it together first time they've been
two on it
since troy polomolo and larry fitzgerald
and there's aaron rodgers
when the reigning mvp isn't on the cover
of the mvp
edition of madden and look it's more
complicated than that because frankly
they may have approached aaron rodgers
and he may have said i want
x million and brady and mahomes said yes
when rogers said no we don't know but
uh there's a reason why peyton manning
was never on the cover of madden i think
the reason is
they never wanted to give him the big
man all right big cat you got a trivia
question for me
the the draft today the all-time best
madden covers
for the first pick i'll try to answer
the question and i'll probably get it
wrong
okay ea sports approached two people to
headline their football game franchise
before they signed
john madden the first was joe montana
the second
was
the second was uh i don't know i'll give
you guys
i mean they had joe montana football
with the sega genesis i remember that
former vikings qb
turned head coach that probably gives it
away head coach
vikings quarterback turned head coach
what vikings quarterback became a head
coach
go ahead i i give i yield joe cap who
an endorsement with atari and cap
demanded royalties
joe cap football oh god
that would have worked been around for
all right
go ahead uh number one's easy for me
well wait are we doing only players
all-time best madden covers okay all
right
you know what my number one is still the
same the michael vick cover michael vick
was so electric and madden
he was the most electric player in
madden that cover
that arrival that is my favorite madden
there it is
i that's the universal like everyone
will say yes good pick big cat
way to go but that's the ultimate
example of a curse he broke his leg in
the preseason against the ravens that
year right after the game
came out guess what people remember a
lot more
how awesome he was to be in that game
all right i'll go with the
original i got to the original john
madden football
before they put years to it they didn't
know what it was going to be i remember
seeing it
on the shelf at the store back when they
used to have
stores that had shelves with video games
on them
there he is john madden football because
let me just give you the little i i
spent years trying to find
a football video game that would
actually be fun to play i have suffered
through
some crap football games whether it's
the atari football which
wasn't football it was like some sort of
space invaders
and and the in television football we
had to program the plays and the center
of the nose tackle didn't move
i have spent years playing horrible
football games
john madden by virtue of the fact that
ea sports bought out the 2k5 license
because that would have probably been a
better game over the long haul
but at least john madden football
evolved into something that is fun to
play
and realistic so that started it all
that's the one that's my first choice
good job mike way to go did you buy that
how'd you get to the store to buy that
on your dinosaur um
all right i'm gonna go with my next pick
this one's easy this is maybe the most
iconic for all the wrong reasons the
peyton hillis cover
i it's still like the best i think about
it so
often he scored uh after this
cover in the nfl he had six total
touchdowns for the rest of his career
six six he was peyton hillis
i can't believe he made a cover it's
everyone
like if you ever want to say hey kid you
can be anything
point to peyton hillis being on the
madden cover it's it's
incredible he had one good year and he
wanted to get paid and he never could
get paid and it drove him nuts and i
remember there was a game he didn't play
because he had like a sore throat and
alex mack played with
appendicitis and that kind of
encapsulates the peyton hillis
experience in the nfl
all right i'll go madden 09 brett favre
in the packers uniform
considering that in 2008 he unretired
and played for the jets that year
that to me is he was no longer a packer
he was a jet that year he'd be a viking
n09 bra i'll never forget that and that
was really kind of
that kind of you know big time franchise
hall of fame quarterback on the cover of
madden and also we
it's well documented how aggressively
john madden loved him from brett favre
so i guess it was fitting
all right my last pick all right so i
have i have my last pick real quick is
ray lewis
uh it's ray lewis because it's the birth
of the hit stick which was awesome
first defensive player on the on the
cover also look how ferocious he is
also mike i got an extra choice pick
actually you do your last pick and then
i'll do the fourth pick
i dominated i got brady i got brady 2018
with the primal scream i love any
example brady with his private screen
there he is primal screaming
i like it i dominated this draft i have
a special edition the blogger edition
let's see it
look at that look at that
they should make this game for you my
god how old were you
how old was i it's one of the
iconic pictures i took it's probably
about four or five years ago so fat
in this huge shirt i don't know if you
have the regular the full picture
if you can pull that up but it's it's an
iconic
fat picture of mine but we need this we
need this where you can just criticize
players
we're on hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports